today we're going to be speaking with
david pepper who's the former chair of
the ohio democratic party teaches
election law at university of cincinnati
law school and is also author of the
book laboratories of autocracy a wake-up
call from behind the lines it's really
great having you on david
thank you it's good to be with you so uh
yeah i think maybe to to start with
there's so many different places where
we could look and talk about autocracy
authoritarian tendencies and beyond
sometimes people talk about voter
disenfranchisement and suppression
techniques at the state level we
obviously have this big national story
of the multi-pronged effort to take an
election that they didn't actually win
in november of 2020. there's all these
different things a control of school
curricula i mean when you look at
autocracy what are the most concerning
kind of bullet points that you start
with
so i'd say my biggest concern is that we
focus on some of the most prominent
people like trump and we should
but my biggest worry is the other side
that has you know some of the players
have been at this for a long time
and while we focus on the high profile
people and the things that make a lot of
noise and the bright shiny objects like
barger taylor green
they're focused on the institutions
that either support democracy or if
weakened
could usher in you know the lack of
democracy or ultimately something that i
think is referred to often as
competitive autocracy
and the reason i wrote the book is to
say you know it's it reminds me of the
movie don't look up which i was at first
afraid to watch but then glad i did it's
saying don't only look at washington the
institutions that shape our democracy in
so many ways are states
one side figured that out a long time
ago they have a minority view that can
only survive in a world without robust
democracy so they've had their eye and
tentacles on the states for a long time
and they're converting them into as i
describe laboratories of autocracy
that are non-stop undermining
key you know principles and tenants and
protections for democracy
and it's accelerating and so it's sort
of look at the institutions
don't just look at our usual politics
which is you know federal majorities one
through swing districts and swing states
look at the institutions that shape
democracy those are largely state houses
yes the federal government can do
important things to protect against
those they must but the heart of it is
at the state level and i just think one
side has been blind to that for a
generation the other side has been
focused on it like a laser and are
scoring victory after victory because of
that
so competitive autocracy competitive
authoritarianism that's a term i've used
with my audience before this this is
important to understand this is that you
have at least i say in theory but maybe
some people would say in principle
democratic institutions and electoral
competition but it's not really fair
competition is that generally the gist
of it yeah it's it's it's
rigging things in advance
it's minority rule locked in
with a veneer of legitimacy with the
with the illusion that everything was
fair and up for grabs
and you know it it sounds very sort of
um that's that's quite an accusation
but
we know where what it looks like it
looks like hungary and so we make this
accusation
it's not really rebuttable anymore
because they're all going to hungary
celebrating it in the wide open you know
tucker carlson cpac trump you know
endorsing orbon they're not hiding that
the competitive autocracy system
that that you know we see in other
countries is that what they want when
they embrace hungary and as i as i go
through the book
almost every element that hungary is
going through rigging legislative
elections suppressing votes in the
opposition party attacking courts
almost every element that hungary you
know go through the checklist is going
through
you could overlay into state house after
state house in our country it's the same
pattern so it's not like they're only
celebrating it in 2022
it's either they've been modeling off of
it or just doing the same thing on their
own for years
and so yeah it's it is what it is the
model and that's why i think
one of the reasons i wrote the book is
not simply to say hear the elements of
it we should be concerned about
but we have to move away from doing
things that unintentionally legitimize
it all
and when we're too silent
when we
when we treat it as politics as normal
by applying the by allowing the
filibuster to stop us from stopping it
by
treating it like any other issue we play
into
the you know the competitive autocracy
end goal which is not only to to sort of
suppress democracy but to make everyone
think that it's it actually still is
there in in a viable way so right that's
the key point right because if they need
to seem legitimate if people believe
it's legitimate they are less likely to
rise up against it
correct and it sustains for much longer
you know again what is not an effective
competitive autocracy storming a
building that was not what you do that
was literally i'm sure orban was like um
no that does not look legitimate the key
to my success is not
openly you know trying to overturn an
election
it's actually just subtly
predetermined outcomes
everyone votes and you wipe your hand to
say hey look election happened i won
again for the tenth time even though i'm
in the minority so so that's why i think
we you know
it and some may not like this but that's
why i thought it was good when those
texas legislators left texas
they were declaring this illegitimate
you don't normally leave your state i
wouldn't recommend that but if something
is so illegitimate that if you just sit
there and vote no and it passes the
voters may think well that's just
politics as normal it's reaching a point
where i think of people who are fighting
for democracy have to call this out and
that's why
to me the senate needs to keep amping it
up joe biden can't go silent again um if
if we if we have to force chuck grassley
and
uh josh hawley and cruz to debate for
two weeks on end to stop our our votes
to protect democracy great make them do
it because competitive autography relies
on a sense that it's legitimate and
normal we know it's not but i think too
rarely do we actually act in that way
which is allowing it to continue so one
of the um discussions that i often have
with people who watch my show with other
guests or whoever really is
to what extent do you focus on changing
the system versus using the system to
our advantage and the prototypical
example is the the gerrymandering
redistricting which is right obviously
i would rather and many of the people in
my audience would rather a system to
prevent gerrymandering to begin with
whether it's a nonpartisan redistricting
commission whatever whatever the way it
is you prevent the problem but until
that happens is there any choice but to
take every opportunity to gerrymander
for your side because otherwise they're
going to gerrymander how do you strike
this balance and is there is it a great
question
yeah i mean a gerrymandering is bad no
matter what it i try and show in the
book and i go through you know so my
book one way to think about it i do hope
everyone gets it because
no interview can sort of get into the
details sure and my i wrote it to be
read and shared because i'm so alarmed
but i it's think of my book as sort of
what's the matter with kansas with a lot
of focus on ohio but the point is about
democracy itself and i walk through that
once you have the non-democratic world
of gerrymandering where no one's
accountable this is going to be true for
anyone who does it although they do a
lot worse than we do this is not a both
sides issue
public outcomes crater in these
non-democratic rig state houses because
the incentives that we normally expect
on politicians and democracy good public
outcomes don't be corrupt all the
account all the incentives that come
with the accountability democracy
disappear in these rigged systems so
ohio under this terribly rigged
non-democratic state house has seen our
educate our public education fail our
health care outcomes in the low 40s
highest level student debt in the
country so no one should be stuck in a
state house with no democracy it's just
bad but to your point
there's going to be a natural
race to the bottom if one side sees one
doing it especially on the congressional
level and if they don't do it then they
lose power and this is why
it doesn't have to be either or this is
why the federal legislation
that would provide guard rails for
everybody is so important and i want
everything there to pass but but the
legislation in the freedom the vote act
would basically come up with some rules
about what an unconstitutional
gerrymander looks like
i'm sorry or an illegal gerrymander in
the federal law uh may not be deemed
unconstitutional but it could be deemed
illegal
that would basically say whether
whatever state you are there are certain
rules you have to follow you're
violating the law and the congress has
the right to do that that's the best way
to avoid what you talked about change
the system add guard rails and don't put
any state in a position
that that it's creating basically a lack
of democracy and all the terrible
results that come in by the way
we in ohio we did pass two
constitutional amendments
uh we elected a fair supreme court we
showed in the last couple weeks that a
court will uphold fair rules
if if you have them in place and that's
why the court struck down a really bad
map here that's a win for democracy the
best in the last generation ohio but it
shows that that federal legislation
could do the same thing so there's a way
to avoid that that terrible choice by
establishing rules that everyone has to
follow
many in our audience understand and uh
are aware of the push to privatization
that exists in a number of different
areas in in society in the book you talk
about how a lot of that is actually
happening thanks to state legislatures
can you give a couple examples of that
because i think oftentimes the
assumption is that it's happening as as
a result of things that politicians in
washington dc are doing
no the so the the big private players
have figured out over the last 20 years
to get the worst hairiest most unpopular
and most inconsistent with public
outcomes
parts of their agenda done
you go to the state houses that's where
you do it because no one's paying
attention
these people are rigged so they can
never lose their election even when they
do really stupid and honorable things
and so examples of that in ohio
they drain public schools of funding for
a generation to give it to for-profit
charter school online outfits some of
which have been total scams
and the politicians even though the
schools in their own backyards are
plummeting and have less money
and the public and the and the private
players they've helped who've given them
money the whole time have literally
turned into scandals
they've only won because of it they've
never lost so that's a great example you
know in ohio we've been draining money
we the state house has been pulling
money out of local governments for a
decade to give it out as tax cuts at the
high end the entire trickle down theory
is in play in almost every state again
it would not be sustainable the shape of
small towns and school districts is
collapsing it wouldn't be sustainable in
a normal democracy because the results
are indefensible but in this rigged
world where they can't lose these
players have figured out
you couldn't get it done in washington
it's too hard but in it and again get
coverage in a way that that that would
be a problem right
but that betsy devos agenda
a state house will do it without
thinking twice and for the most part no
one even knows and there are examples
all over the country in in one of my
advice pieces of advice in my book to
anyone running don't talk about most of
what we're talking about right now in
your 30-second general election ad
find the public outcome that is the most
horrific
in kansas it was the fact that they had
school four days a week right and laura
kelly won on that issue she could have
said anything in the world about kris
kobach did a lot of democrats might have
said we agree but she was smart enough
to say the true issue where i can
explain the impact of this corruption
and this privatization of everything at
the state level and how it impacts
public outcomes people care about the
best example of school four days a week
in texas
it's an energy grid collapsing so that
people froze to death a year ago and
beta o'rourke is doing a great job on
that focusing on that it's we have to
translate
the the corrosion of the public asset
public good and the common good is
endemic to these broken privatized state
houses and we have to be smart enough to
not just you know
run around saying the sky is falling
although it arguably is falling quickly
is to say
the reason you everyday voters should
care about this is your town and your
school and your roads and everything
else are in worse shape because the koch
brothers have essentially taken over
your state house
in the um in the just minute we have
left other than registering to vote and
voting in every election where you can
vote
what are the what's the low-hanging
fruit that people in the audience should
be doing uh it's it's go broader and
then registering although that's a very
important part of it in states like
george and ohio think about your
footprint that you have of influence and
think about all the ways that you can
use that footprint to lift democracy and
it's bigger than you imagine if you're
on the board of a homeless shelter is
the homeless shelter engaging those it
serves or a food bank do you know the
mayor of a town are they registering
voters in their rec centers in their
libraries
scale it up if you run a small business
is part of your mission of that business
lift democracy and again it's
registration it's engagement once people
are registered it's early vote just
think
literally sit down and write down what's
my footprint and i go through all the
details in the book and and
engage that footprint as much as you can
to lift democracy and that includes
helping people run for state office
state house office board of education
you name it registering but use your
footprint don't wait for stacey abrams
to save the day or michelle obama don't
just assume people are going to get
registered the bureau of motor vehicles
use the things you do every day to also
lift democracy
and that's the way i think we start
hitting a scale especially when we know
that every single day the other side
is attacking those same voters and
attacking democracy so if you're not
doing this stuff
we're not just
holding steady we're losing ground in a
lot of these states without a doubt the
book is laboratories of autocracy a
wake-up call from behind the lines we've
been speaking with the book's author
david pepper uh david really appreciate
your time today
thank you great talking to you thanks
for all you all you talk about every day